monty towing the slab of the boogie down
here in a soupy night probably it's like
you know it's a little misty a little
foggy you hard to see the ball a little
bit maybe
yeah you know those knights you've had
many of them pretty good numbers the
five home runs kind of jump
out but eight walks and 24 strikeouts
well the weather has not
dampened their enthusiasm so he gets the
same reception as he did
last night just get the feeling he's
gonna hear that
in this stadium for the rest of his
career
jose altuve first pitch swinging and
that's a base hitting the left field
that's one way to try and quiet your
critics with a first pitch base hit
let's get this game started now it's
michael brantley's turn swung on and
granted a second
flip it to short one on the first double
play
it's a four six three double play
the mayhew to torres to first and they
were to it
in the bronx tonight luis garcia is
going to be your starting pitcher
some of the numbers on him as far as
first pitch strike percentage they're
very good at home in comparison to road
the strike percentage is
up at home also the walk percentage down
he's been very good at home the average
versus righties has been an 0.53 but
once he gets on the road
starts to fall behind in some of these
counts and they have a chance to get to
some of the pitches that he leaves out
over the zone
light rain continues to fall in the
bronx as dj lemayo leads it off
batting 278 swing and a foul tip into
the glove of castro
the mayhew strikes out went away boy a
great start
striking out a big time hitter in le
mayhew with the fastball inside
so one out of no one on for gen carlos
stanton hit a two-run home run yesterday
swinging a mess struck him out on a
slider down and away back-to-back case
for garcia two out
so i just drawn a lot of walks lately
he's reaching 24
his last 53 played appearances swinging
at a miss
got him on the cutter down and away luis
garcia strikes out the side
in the first inning so here is jordan
alvarez the big
lefty-hitting first baseman outfielder
for houston
that alvarez strikes out against
montgomery montgomery
really over maxed alvarez right there
one away here's correa
swing and a miss correa down on strikes
and two straight strikeouts for
montgomery so here is gorielle
half swing in the dirt breaking ball
strike three
he struck out the side did montgomery so
montgomery comes right back
with a very good curveball so the batter
now will be out too big
with the runner on third base swung on
and grounded to third
a shell of fields throws across in time
so they waste
a couple of singles to start things now
here's lamehu
and the pitch knocks him down we haven't
seen one of these all night but just a
fastball
up and in a boy that was up and then hit
the back of the arm of dj
le mayhew while now gets a little more
interesting
the runner at first and two out there's
a man with a 10-game hitting streak
john carlos stanton swung on out
[Applause]
oh did he touch one off the deep left
center field
giancarlo
[Applause]
it's a two-run blast a blaster
and the yankees take a two-nothing read
you know and that's how you get back
in something you don't like that if you
watch your second baseman do something
about it
and stanton is not missing the ball out
over the plate
when it gets into the bleachers at the
left you've hit it a ton
107 miles an hour off the bat 435 just
missed it
the base is loaded nobody out for carlos
correa who is four for eight against him
with a home run
hard hit ground ball right side nice
play le mayhew they get the out at
second on alvarez runs scores michael
brantley crosses the plate
hits sharply by correa but an out on the
fielder's choice carlos gets an rbi it's
now
two to one game so now it's guriel who
leads the team in rbis
with runners on the corners and one out
swing and a line shot down the left
field line
and it is off the wall bregman will
score easily
as guriel coasts into second base with
the double they're going to see correa
and he is out of the plate beautiful
relay by the yankees the astros trying
to score
but the relay throw kept it from the
astros going ahead
and now let miss diaz will bat he
singled his last time up
that ball's hit hard that is going to be
a fair ball down the line that will give
the astros their first lead of the night
as julie giriel will score
oled miss diaz 2 for 2 and rbi double
it's a 3-2 ball game it doesn't seem to
matter how long diaz has sat
how long it's been since he started he
gets hits and big hits for the astros
so gardner's at second and le mayhew is
at first and at the plate one of the
hottest
hitters in baseball giancarlo stanton
lined hard base hit
over third down the left field on
rolling to the left field corner
gardner has scored and they'll have to
hold lemayo at third
the amazing stanton continues in rbi
double and the game is tied at three
could anyone be hotter than jean carlos
stanton who is now
up to 308. here is uh gardner with the
bases loaded two uh what
and gardner pops it up on the infield
stanek is under it called off now by
guriel who makes the catch with both
hands stanic of this pump and the
yankees leave them loaded
astral is going to face a new pitcher
it's gonna be the left-hander wandy
peralta one of their four lefties out of
the pen we saw him last night
castro will face the left-hander here
and that pitch is over his head
straw doesn't have to worry about a
stolen base he easily goes to second
well if you're scoring at home write wp
in capital letters that wild pitch
because that's about as wild as it gets
now the go-ahead run is in scoring
position castro tonight is 0 for 2
wrapped into a 4-6-3 double play and fly
ball right
and he struck a mouse no runs no hits
and one left le mayhew is off second
stanton off first and here's urshella
swings at the first one could be two
correa's got it shovels to altuve
on the first base double play how about
that brian abreu
and the yankees are done in the seventh
on first and second and nobody out
hicks is one for three swung on and
luke down the right via line it is gonna
drop in for a basin
rounding third here comes taurus here
comes the throw
and he scores it's a basin and an rbi
for aaron hicks and the yankees take a
4-3
lead so the yanks have the bases loaded
with no one out
and that'll bring up gardner fly ball
left field
tagging his way brentley makes the catch
the throw will go into third wade scores
it's a sac fly for gardner
and the yankees lead by two five to
three so gardner at first
hicks at third and with two outs here is
giancarlo
for and the yankees lead
six to three he continues to wield a
magic wand the astros fakes the yankees
closer here are aldous chapman
last time the astro saw chapman he was
standing on the mound and smiling after
a walk-off home run couldn't believe
jose altuve took him out to end the alcs
in 2019.
and that leaves it up to julie aguriel
struck him out swinging ball game over
yankees win
yankees win so the yankees have won
their fifth
straight game